after the Russian government was
overthrown by the Bolsheviks in late
1917 the Anton sought to intervene they
saw soldiers from those Nations enter
Russia across numerous fronts this was
in order to secure resources bolster
their allies and prevent either from
falling into German hands in Russia's
Far East Japan led a major Intervention
which saw it invade Siberia and occupy
all of these lands and given Japan's
antagonistic history with Russia and its
hatred of all things communist Why
didn't it use the opportunity to take
Siberia for itself so when Russia left
the first world war in 1917 the Anton
were quite concerned the largest army
had just left and soon afterwards its
new leaders had handed the Central
Powers all of this and so France Britain
and later the United States opted to
intervene at first Japan was very
reluctant to get involved with
intervening in Russia and this was
because if things went wrong it may have
found itself caught up in a major land
War near its borders and as such the
Japanese government chose to sit it out
that was until the Anton decided to go
in without them Britain Canada and the
United States wanted to secure the Divo
stock and so made plans to occupy the
region around it Japan didn't want to be
left out and so quickly agree to join
the invasion in 1918. it was asked to
provide about 10 000 men for the
operation which they did followed by a
further sixty thousand men just to be
sure such a large Force concerned the
British and the Americans who thought
that maybe Japan wasn't just looking to
secure a port for trade the plan had
just been to occupy these lands to
secure the port however Japan kept on
pushing him by 1920 they were up to here
the government had also settled tens of
thousands of Japanese civilians in the
region and gave mineral rights to
Japanese companies which signaled that
maybe they were there to stay once their
allies had been evacuated and it became
clear that the Bolsheviks were going to
win the ontant withdrew thus leaving the
region to the Communists well at least
they had thought because the Japanese
chose to stay and those in the Army were
pushing the government to either Annex
the region or set up a permanent puppet
state to act as a buffer against the
Communists Japanese politicians did not
agree with the Army though the problem
was that the rest of the Autumn were
very uneasy about Japan grabbing so much
land the United States especially was
angered by the expansion of an Empire
which it had mixed history with
especially given that further expansion
in Siberia could potentially put Japan
right next door to Alaska and also even
with the Japanese plantations most of
the people who lived in the region
didn't want the Japanese to stay and
given Japan's support for siberia's
puppet rulers who frankly weren't the
nicest the people in the region just
wanted them gone another issue was that
with the rest of the Anton gone Japan
had to face the Bolsheviks alone and the
Bolsheviks were now able to bring a lot
more Force to bear on Siberia this meant
that if Japan wanted to keep the region
it would need to commit hundreds of
thousands of men and lots of money and
resources to do so furthermore to make
things more complicated the Japanese
government didn't trust the Army there
were concerns that generals were lying
about casualty rates and what the
polsheviks could actually do to retake
Siberia and since they weren't 100 sure
they weren't going to risk it and so the
Japanese government agreed to withdraw
and left Siberia in 1922 and in the end
this was something that the Japanese
weren't too upset about because its
somewhat light intervention in the first
world war had seen the country gain
Germany's colonies in the region for
very little effort meaning that by the
1920s Japan had still come out ahead I
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for watching with a special thanks
to my patrons James bisonnet Kelly
moneymaker course show wolf cartoon
Jerry lambdin Jordan Longley Alex
Schwinn Marcus arsner way in hockey
Spencer Lightfoot Marvin cassau Captain
psydog the mcguoper Miss is it
winston-kwood Community Wiggly Gustav
Swan Aaron the white Daniel tobian
Anthony Beckett Maggie Paskowski
sherwenin spinning three plates words
about books podcast Coppertone and
Charles the first